[Music]
hey you guys welcome to day three of eek
week remember yesterday when i posted
the review of the innocence i said i had
completely accidentally uh done two
movies that were directed by the same
guy i i did not mean to do that by any
stretch of the imagination because as
you know if you watch my innocence
review it was directed by jack clayton
and this movie is directed by jack
clayton too and it's really weird i only
remembered to do this one because it was
one that i remembered fondly from my
childhood and then also i was like i
said i was kind of looking to because
there was a couple movies that i had
wanted to do originally for this series
but then i couldn't get hold of them for
whatever reason like they weren't
streaming uh wherever i was so uh so i
was kind of going through
the wikipedia page of movies set at
halloween and trying to like hit ones
that i hadn't got around to doing yet
and i remembered this when i was like oh
yeah i really need to do that one so i
started looking for it it was a [ __ ] to
find i finally had to end up just
watching like a free shitty one on
youtube but i'd seen this movie before
so it wasn't really that big a deal and
then later on i remembered that it was
also directed by jack clayton the same
guy who had directed the innocence back
in 1961 and this is something wicked
this way comes from 1983.
interestingly too i was watching some
other reviews of it and one of my
favorite horror channels grumpy andrew
who is a british guy he does grumpy
andrew's horror house or something like
that and uh last year around halloween
he had also done the innocence and the
next day something wicked this way comes
to jack clayton movies and again i did
not know that he had done that so it's
like i'm not trying to sorry grumpy
andrew i'm not like ripping you off or
anything it just it was a complete
coincidence i didn't even like i didn't
even remember that these two movies were
uh directed by the same person so you
know i'm just getting that out of the
way right now
so as i said something wicked this way
comes this is a very interesting
film coming out as it did in 1983
this was it was actually made by disney
but this was right around the time
period because remember if you grew up
during this era i kind of feel like
disney were you know obviously were well
known for doing all their animation and
all this other stuff but it seems like
in the 70s and 80s they were kind of at
sixes and sevens um some things that
happened that
they felt like they were maybe kind of
getting behind the culture uh because
you know obviously they had been offered
uh to do star wars and they passed on it
thinking it wasn't gonna do anything and
you know and they kind of got their ass
handed to them on that there was various
other things and i kind of feel like
like a new guy had taken over who i
think i want to say was walt disney's
son-in-law i think had taken over
and he's like look you know we need to
like catch up with the times everybody
just knows this is like this
family-friendly like animation studio
and maybe we need to you know shake
things up a bit get things you know stop
thinking so inside the box and whatnot
so they started making
a series of
in hindsight like at the time they were
not super successful films but in
hindsight they made some really really
interesting decisions
in the sense that
they were still making
what could ostensibly be called family
friendly films but a lot of them had
kind of a darker edge or you know like a
little bit more of a horror or sci-fi
sensibility um this around the time well
i mean it was earlier than that but they
made like the black hole which i think
came out in the very late 1970s they
made the watcher in the woods which was
kind of pretty much a horror movie you
know they did like the black cauldron
they were so i think they were still
trying to do family friendly but they
were trying to appeal to a slightly
older audience or
trying to do something a little bit
darker edgier this was also around the
same time period that they did uh return
to oz that really that really really
creepy [ __ ] with fariza bach and stuff
like that so i feel i feel like this is
an era in disney that even though it
wasn't financially successful and it's
some in some senses the movies weren't
entirely successful either and this one
is kind of an example of that you know
it was interesting that they were trying
something like this and a lot of the
movies that they made during this time
period kids that grew up during this era
like really remember them fondly because
it's like they were still family
friendly but they still had this really
creepy like dark sensibility to them and
this movie something wicked this way
comes really does fall right into that
uh that that kind of weird era and uh it
was financially pretty much a bomb
and i saw it a bunch back in the day and
i remember liking it but not loving it
because i was a big like ray bradberry
fan you know i was really into you know
and i was all into like that twilight
zone kind of vibe which this uh
definitely has
i would also kind of put this in the
same ballpark
as like the lady in white which i talked
about you know a couple months back i
think even though i should have saved it
for halloween but i wasn't thinking
about it because that's totally like a
very very halloweeny type of movie you
know that came out a lot later but i
feel like it still kind of like occupies
the same kind of space where it's like a
family
like you can watch it with kids
but there's still like some really
really dark themes and there's like some
really creepy [ __ ] in it so even adults
can like watch it and enjoy it and it's
a good i think it's like one of those
good starter films like if you have a
kid
that seems like they're interested in
wanting to watch scary stuff and horror
and you don't want them you know seeing
really really scary [ __ ] but this seems
like it's you know right in the middle
and i remember being a kid and this
being
you know really really the the kind of
thing that when i was little like really
would have appealed to me i believe i
was well i would have been 11 when this
came out and i don't think i saw it in
the theater i mean my parents very well
could have taken me to see it in the
theater but i kind of feel like maybe i
saw it a year or two later like on cable
and like i said i had read the book i
don't remember if i read the book before
i saw the movie or if i read the book
because i know that i was reading like
stephen king's dance macabre
when i was younger maybe i was a little
bit older then and he like talked a lot
about ray bradbury and he talks about
the novel
so i know that i read it at some point
but i might have already seen the movie
so what ended up happening with this uh
this is based on a ray bradbury novel
although
it's weird because ray bradbury who
actually like back in the 50s was
friends with gene kelly now something
wicked this way comes the book actually
first started out as a screenplay and he
wrote it for a movie and gene kelly was
supposed to direct it and this was like
back in the late 1950s
but i guess um they never really could
get the project off the ground you know
no studio wanted it
so over the next few years uh ray
bradbury rewrote it and wrote it into a
novel and that came out in 1962
and then like about 10 years later
everybody started thinking well maybe we
should adapt this because it is like a
really cool story and it is very this is
a good one to watch around halloween too
because it's even though it's not like
explicitly halloween but it's obviously
set around october it's very autumnal it
has that very you know autumn kind of
vibe to it and in the book actually it
does take place like several days like
the week before halloween or something
like that so it does really have that
kind of like seasonal
vibe to it which i think is which the
lady in white has also and it also has
that nostalgic
sort of dream like
idealized 1950s americana kind of thing
to it too although i would argue that
this one at least visually and story
wise is darker and goes like in a more
fantasy like a dark fantasy direction
than lady and white which is more just
like a murdered ghost story type thing
this one is a lot more like fantasy
based
so in the early 1970s when they were
talking about adapting it at first uh
sam peckinpah was actually going to
direct it which might have been
interesting but uh yeah but that didn't
uh really work out
i think kirk douglas was going to play
one of the roles in it they i think they
were going to make it for six million
dollars like in the early seventies but
again it just it never got made project
never got off the ground so then in the
late 70s uh they started talking about
it again
and ray bradbury had worked together
with jack clayton who as i mentioned
directed the innocence among many other
things and uh they had worked together
before so they decided they were gonna
collaborate on on the uh on the project
and again for the third time uh it
didn't really go anywhere even though
there were interests uh like i said sam
pekinpot was directing it uh maybe gonna
direct it steven spielberg was also
seemed to be interested which also might
have been really interesting although i
don't i feel like if steven spielberg
had done it
it probably would have been a good movie
but i don't know if it would have been
as dark or as weird or as like strange i
don't know it's kind of a strange movie
like i said because as i mentioned at
this time walt disney studios was kind
of looking for more properties that were
sort of darker or aimed toward
still a family but like an older
slightly older children uh so they
became interested in the project so they
kind of took it on
so uh at first they were kind of like uh
i think ray bradbury actually wanted
christopher lee to play mr dark who is
you know kind of the main villain
or perhaps peter o'toole but disney were
like yeah we're not paying those dudes
salaries
so uh they got uh actually happily they
got jonathan price who at that point was
not super well known but
honestly i think jonathan price is the
best thing about this movie uh as mr
dark he just is so
i mean i love jonathan price anyway he's
like great in everything this was one of
his earlier films like i think he'd been
in films before but you know he wasn't
super super well known uh so obviously
he didn't have to pay him as much as you
would have had to pay christopher lee
but i mean christopher lee would have
been great to see too he would have made
a great uh villain but i just there's
just something about jonathan price in
this role that's like really really good
because he's kind of like
he comes across as very sinister but he
also comes across as
someone that you could believe
uh people would kind of be uh attracted
to him or like um you know kind of fall
into like his trap or whatever you know
what i mean he just was very charismatic
so what we have here i don't know if how
many how many people here have like read
the book this is a fairly faithful
adaptation although i do kind of it's
been a long time since i've read the
book but i do kind of feel like they
took a lot of stuff out because
obviously the book has a lot more like a
lot richer type stuff going in it but so
what you have is there's this small town
uh i think it's called green town
illinois
which is uh based on the town i think uh
ray bradbury grew up in waukegan and uh
so it's based on that so it's a very
very i don't think that that the movie
ever specifically says what year it is
but
you you get like i said a very idealized
50s americana small town uh type of vibe
from this
so in this small town there are there
are two main characters are these two
young boys i think there's 12 or 13 or
something like that
and one of them is named will holloway
and the other one is named jim
nightshade now obviously these two boys
i don't remember if they go into this if
they mention this in the movie but it's
definitely a big thing in the book is
that both boys they live next door to
each other and they're best friends
uh they were both born on halloween but
they were only born like a minute apart
and jim
is blonde and uh or no jim is
dark-haired and will is blonde so
obviously and stephen king talks about
this when he talks about the novel like
he talks about this at great length how
it's this whole apollonian dionysian
type of uh type of uh you know vibe
that's going where it's like the they're
both good boys but they're like the
light and dark side of this of boyhood i
guess you could call it because will is
kind of like more you know he you have
to follow the rules and he's very good
and very upstanding whereas jim isn't a
bad kid but he's kind of more hey let's
sneak into the circus after dark and
let's you know get into trouble type of
thing even though it's not
super malicious he's just real you know
he's mischievous uh type of thing so
these two boys like i said they're even
at the beginning they're still trying to
like they they have been best friends a
long time like pretty much their whole
lives because they grew up next door to
each other will's family i guess his mom
doesn't really factor the story all that
much but there's kind of like a big
thing at the center of the story like
will's relationship with his dad who in
the movie is played by jason robards and
he's also really great in this i really
like this role of his it's very
understated but there's a lot going on
like in
some of the things that he says and like
his body language and his facial
expression and stuff and one of the
hallmarks of uh of jim's or
rather will's relationship with his dad
is that his dad
was
much older when will was born i think he
was in his 50s and he's a librarian and
he has a heart condition
and so
he feels as though
he um couldn't really give will the
boyhood that he deserved because he's
like you know i was always older and i
was kind of like in poor health so i
couldn't like play baseball with him and
stuff like that and there was also an
incident which happened a while back
that he still feels guilty for where
apparently will fell into like a pond or
something like that and started to drown
and because his dad was in poor health
and his dad had never taught him how to
swim
he didn't jump in and save him and so
will was actually saved by jim
nightshade's dad who jumped in and saved
him now interestingly the nightshade
family the dad even though that guy like
jumped in and saved well like i guess he
could swim
jim's dad apparently just took off he's
not really in the picture anymore so
he's being raised by a single mom who in
the movie is played by diane ladd she's
not in it a great deal she's kind of
portrayed as
sort of an over the hill
woman not
desperate for love but kind of like you
know like jim comes home a few times and
finds her like dancing with a new guy
and all this other kind of stuff so you
can tell she's kind of like
he either really wants her husband back
or thinks he's gonna come back someday
even though jim's pretty sure that he's
not um or she's kind of like trying to
get with a new man you know probably
understandably because it's the 1950s
um and as i said jim seems like
he's even though he's a minute younger
than will i believe so he's always kind
of like you know it's just a minute he
always wants to be like older because
he's kind of starting to get interested
in girls and things like that and will
is still
not really like you know so they're
still so one of them is maybe growing up
faster than the other one so there's
that kind of whole thing too
now into this little small town
americana sort of vibe
comes a carnival
now the carnival comes in autumn which
is unusual because usually they come in
summertime and so everyone's kind of
talking about that it's like oh that's
kind of weird like this train showing up
and also it shows up on this train in
the middle of the night
and
will and jim are pretty much because
they're coming home late at night
because they got uh detention or
something for for acting up in class
they actually sneak down there to see it
because they can kind of see the train
coming from their window and they're
like whoa what the hell is that all
about so they go down there and
essentially the carnival
like sets itself up like in just like a
couple of minutes it's like it's just
like all there so obviously there's
something like magical and perhaps even
diabolical uh going on about this
carnival
now
the carnival which is run by mr dark i
think in the movie it's called mr dark's
pandemonium carnival i think in the book
it's called cougar and dark's
pandemonium shadow show which i really
really like but maybe they thought that
was a little too over the top for the
movie i'm not really sure but uh yeah
because there is another guy named mr
cougar
who with two o's who uh is also kind of
part of it but mr dark played by
jonathan price
is ostensibly the head of the carnival
and you're led to believe over the
course of it and this is not a spoiler
of or any uh stretch the imagination
because like i said this this novel is
very old and the uh you know the movie
is old as well he's essentially they
don't come right out and say he's like
the devil but he is like a very
mephistopheles
type of character or you know where he's
like um
a tempter essentially
and uh i think even one of the train
cars like one of the shots when it's
first coming in is called like the tent
of temptation or something like that
so basically when this carnival sets up
and of course everybody in town goes to
it because it's a small town and it's
the 50s and that's just what you do
there are a couple of things that and
this is in this sense it's like the
twilight zone like i said because it's
almost kind of like a morality tale
because the what the carnival does
is that it seems to give you exactly
what you want like you like your deepest
desire like for example there's um
there's a guy in town who is constantly
reliving his old like football days like
when he was in high school or something
like that but now he was in an accident
or in the war or something like that and
he doesn't have um one of his arms and
his legs was uh amputated so obviously
he can't really play football that well
anymore and um so his greatest dream is
like to have his leg and arm back and
play football again so when he goes to
because i feel like most of the carnival
kind of just looks like a regular ass
carnival you know there's the strength
[ __ ] and like the rides and the ferris
wheel and you know the hoochie coochie
girls or whatever they call them like in
the tent that's what they used to call
them back in the day and uh but the two
kind of
seemingly magical things are
the hall of mirrors which essentially
when you go in it shows you your
greatest desire and then it gives it to
you and then there's also the
merry-go-round which as jim and will
find out when they sneak into the [ __ ]
one night like after closing
is that basically if it runs backwards
it takes a year off your life for every
rotation going backwards and when it
goes forward it you know obviously packs
years on to you so it can make you
younger older essentially like time
machine so uh one by one many of the
townsfolk fall under the spell of mr
dark's carnival
um you know like i said the the football
guy goes into the hall of mirrors and
gets like his leg and arm back and now
you know and it also makes him younger
jim and will's school teacher the one
that put them in detention you know
she's like an older very school marmy
type of you know okay i'm gonna wrap you
with a ruler she's like that kind of
lady but then um the kids are talking
about oh back in the day she was like
the most beautiful woman in town and so
obviously she wants her youth back so
she goes into the hall of mirrors and is
young and beautiful again but
as always with stuff like this
you know you get your deepest desire but
there's always like a sting in the tail
you know what i mean so like
basically she gets to be young and
beautiful but then she's like looking at
herself in the mirror going hey wow look
how hot i am and stuff like that and
then she's blinded so she can't see
herself anymore um you know and then
there's other stuff happens like one guy
like his greatest wish is to be
seduced by a bunch of foreign women or
exotic women or something like that so
he basically gets sucked into the tent
with like all the dancing girls and
there's all this other stuff going on so
there's that's kind of like twilight
zoney episode and i kind of wish cause i
feel like there was more of that in the
book like i said it's been a while since
i read it with all the townsfolk getting
sucked in and getting their greatest
desire but then there being something
like [ __ ] up happening at the end
because you can't just
you know have what you want but mostly
the story focuses on
will and jim and the relationship of
like their relationship sort of
fracturing and also the relationship
between will and his dad
who
at first is you know skeptical as you
would be like when will and jim are like
hey this carnival is like magical and
also possibly evil um and you know
they're trying to tell the adults like
what's going on and not to but
particularly will is trying to like not
get them not get the adults in town to
like fall under the spell of the
carnival because it's evil but of course
they don't believe him at first and you
know will's dad obviously doesn't
believe at first either but then he
starts to
uh starts to believe it even though he's
tempted as well by mr dark who attempts
to
you know get him to take a ride on the
magical merry-go-round that will take
years off his life so he'll get his
youth back he'll be able to be a dad to
will the way he always wanted to be and
he was you know that he was regretful
that he couldn't because he was older
and in poor health and things so he is
tempted but because you know his dad is
a really good solid person um he ends up
not like falling for it so because the
kids
come in there
they sneak in and they see like a bunch
of the evil [ __ ] going on because
basically what the carnival does
and i kind of and i saw the grumpy
andrew pointed this out too because i
was thinking about this when i was
re-watching the movie is that this is
essentially kind of like stephen king's
novel dr sleep uh the true not you know
these kind they're kind of like psychic
vampires they go around like feeding on
people's fear and pain and stuff and
this is essentially what the carnival
does and as they research it like will's
dad finds out that this carnival
apparently shows up in this town i don't
know if it's just this town or just
other ones it's like i said it's kind of
a fable or like a fairy tale so it
doesn't really matter but this carnival
shows up like once every generation
and
lures people in with their greatest
desires and then like kind of takes it
away from them and feeds on their pain
and their fear and their regret so it it
feeds on like negative emotions and it
comes to town like every so often and uh
just kind of gets who it can get and
kind of sucks the life out of them so
that's essentially what it does and like
i said mr dark is kind of like
a
you know he's they don't i don't think
they come out and say that he's the
devil maybe they do i think they
actually do use that word but he is like
a very devilish figure because he's
offering
uh you know these very tempting things
that people might want and a lot of
people take him up on it but of course
you know it's not gonna work out the way
you think it does because that's just
how it goes
so because the kids find out more about
what's going on with the carnival mr
dark apparently like he tries to
kill them or try to like kidnap them and
get them to come with him so there's all
kind of stuff where he's he does this
there's this great scene where
they're uh all the circus people and the
you know the townsfolk that have been
sucked in to that they have like this
creepy kind of like
uh parade like through the middle of the
town which i think in the movie happens
in the daytime but i could have sworn in
the book it happened like at night but i
could be wrong about that because like i
said it's been a long time since i read
it but this this parade that they're
going through town uh they're actually
like looking for the two boys so the two
boys are like trying to hide out and
like try to hide out from this [ __ ]
uh from this [ __ ] carnival because
they know that mr dark is gonna like you
know kill their asses or whatever and
like i said you know there's this whole
thing where will's dad ends up saving
well not only will because uh lying and
tree you know not not uh succumbing to
the temptation of
uh mr dark like making him younger which
she does want to do you can see it in
his face but he's like no i can't do
that because i have to like be there for
my son he also ends up saving jim
nightshade because jim nightshade uh
because he's a more rebellious sort of
character i guess he's more
uh willing to listen to mr dark and he
wants to be older he wants to be like a
big guy
so he wants to get on the merry-go-round
and like you know be an adult so he can
do whatever he wants to do so he
actually does get sucked in and he's
actually on the on the merry-go-round
and uh will's dad actually does end up
saving him off so he's it's almost like
not only was was he able to save
jim you know and
maybe like in a weird way like save his
own kid as well but he's also kind of
like paying back because it took jim
nightshade's dad saved his son so now
he's you know saving
jim nightshade just like the other dad
saved his son so it's kind of like this
whole thing
so because uh they are able to fight the
temptation they are able to kind of like
defeat the circus so you're led to
believe i mean mr dark does get killed
at them like he gets electrocuted
because there's this whole thing at the
very beginning
of this guy named tom fury who's like a
lightning rod salesman and he's comes
into town and he's almost like the
harbinger because he comes there and he
says to like jim and will he's like oh i
sell lightning rods one of your houses
is in danger um so you guys need to buy
this and so later on so jim actually
does buy one but then like later on in
the movie when mr dark is like trying to
get to them i think initially in the
initial script it was supposed to be
like a big hand like coming in the house
which
i agree would it look super cheesy i'm
not sure if they shot it i think they
did shoot it and then when disney saw
the you saw it they were like yeah that
looks fake as hell we can't do that so
what they ended up doing was
instead of like a giant hand coming into
the house they actually had like a
spider attack so they had like a bunch
of uh tarantulas just like coming in
through the ceiling and stuff like that
and they used real tarantulas and it's
not you know super
climactic but it's still like pretty
creepy crawly but because of all the
spiders and stuff like that in there
like the then lightning hits the
lightning rod and the leg makes all the
spiders go away and still because
they're you know magical so there was
this whole thing so interestingly the
thing about this movie is that
there were a lot of production problems
like i said there was all kind of stuff
about like the script um they didn't
have like a massive budget
and
they shot it i guess in the way that
jack clayton wanted that was going with
the um
with the script that ray bradbury wrote
and then bray bradberry fell out with
jack clayton about some things in the
script um you know because there were
some rewrites and there was like arguing
over that and then like i said they did
some sequences you know like the giant
hand thing and then disney were like
yeah we don't like that because it looks
too fake so we have to do something else
so it took a really really long time to
make this because what ended up
happening was disney saw the cut they
didn't like it they said we don't know
how we're gonna market this or it's just
like not what we wanted so then they
spent like another year i think and like
another five million dollars
reshooting some parts of it including
the spiders thing they didn't like the
original score they thought it was too
scary so they had somebody else uh come
in i think it was james horner actually
he came in and did a score which a
little bit star warsy gotta say not
super star wars but there was like a
couple phrases in there that i was like
that sounds a little star warsy to me
but i'm just saying but the original
score they said it was too scary and it
just wasn't gonna apply so this had
massive massive production problems and
in a lot of ways you can kind of see
that because one the edits kind of
strange the pacing is a little strange
some of the reshoots you can tell they
were reshoots because it was you know
however many months later or a year
later however more much it was and the
some of the shots that they did with the
kids that played jim and will the boys
are clearly a little bit older
uh because you know boys at that age
they they grow very quickly so i think
particularly in the spider scene you can
see that they look considerably older so
it's a little strange and i think some
people are confused because i saw one
review that's like yeah they thought for
a second that the two kids had been on
the merry-go-round they like made them
older because they obviously looked
really older so this is a very very
troubled production
and then when it came out
it didn't even make i mean i think it
only made like a few million dollars
like it didn't even make half its budget
back so it was considered like a pretty
dismal failure but that said
this is a decent movie i mean
considering i think when i was watching
it i didn't realize how much of a
[ __ ] of the making of this movie
was
so
now that i know that i can appreciate
how um it's amazing that they pulled a
decent flick
out of that just mire of
fighting and misery and reshoots and
re-editing and rescoring and it was just
all this
you know massive [ __ ] [ __ ] that they
went through to make it
um it's not a great movie and it's not a
it's a good adaptation of the novel
but there's so much of the novel that
could be i kind of feel like as much as
i like this movie like i said jonathan
price is the best thing in it by a mile
jason robards also great in it there's
also uh pam grier is in this as well she
plays the dust witch although she
doesn't really have that much of a part
i don't even remember if she talks and
it does she maybe
but yeah she's only in a couple scenes
like i said diane ladd is in it but
she's also only in a couple scenes so
there's kind of a lot of potential here
uh in the novel so i would actually
really like to see
maybe a series or like a longer film uh
that's kind of a more faithful
adaptation of the book with more of the
cool stuff in it about like the
townsfolk and stuff like that like
getting sucked into this carnival
because like i said this movie is it's
mostly based around the two kids which
is fine i mean because that's kind of
you know what the book was about too but
it would have been neat if they could
have gone more into which they could do
nowadays with you know better special
effects and stuff with a bigger budget
you know you could totally do like some
really cool [ __ ] with all these with all
these uh people in town that were like
yeah i want this see this is my greatest
desire and then going into the into the
hall of mirrors and like having that and
all this you know then it they could all
have like have twilight zone twist to
them and it could all be really like
interrelated and i think that would be
really cool i don't know if they would
do it nowadays because
dark carnival
is such a ubiquitous theme nowadays um i
feel like it wasn't so much maybe in the
80s and obviously in the 60s when this
novel came out it was i guess it was
like a more original idea even though
like i said it was kind of twilight
zoney
in the sense of being like a morality
tale but
i don't know so maybe i don't know if
maybe the dark carnival thing is maybe
oversaturated so i don't know if anybody
would want to see this nowadays but i
actually would because i actually really
like this movie it's a really good movie
to watch around the halloween season
because like i said it's very octobery
it's very autumn you know it has an
autumn vibe to it in the same way that
the lady in white does um and it's also
a really good one to
show to kids who are really they want to
see like a halloween movie that's maybe
scarier than something like hocus pocus
but it's still not as scary as you know
a real horror movie but it's this one
definitely has like a lot more horror
elements than a lot of the disney stuff
the darker disney stuff that came out
around this time period so it's
definitely definitely worth a watch um i
don't think it's streaming anywhere at
the moment might be on disney plus if
you have i don't have disney plus but if
you do um check and see and tell me if
it's on there uh somebody posted on
youtube for free but it's really really
crappy like the the video quality the
audio is okay but
the video quality is awful but you know
since i needed to watch it i was just
kind of like well i've seen it before so
so i'll just like you know give i'll
give this one a whirl so just so i can
get it done
but let me know if uh if you guys have
seen it if it was one that you
remembered from your childhood very
fondly because i know a lot of people
did um and like i said i this was one
that i saw maybe once or twice as a kid
and i remember liking it but i was kind
of like well that you know that was okay
and not really thinking that much about
it so it was like really interesting to
revisit and especially
now like in light of knowing about all
the production problems that it had so i
don't know i'd be interested to see
although like i said jonathan price was
so [ __ ] good in this it's like i'm
not really sure how you could
who would replace him as mr dark because
he really seemed i mean like i said he
was like the best thing about this movie
and honestly i love you know what i love
about this too i love the [ __ ] poster
back in the old days when they used to
do paintings for the posters instead of
like you know photoshopped
photo collages there was like a gorsen
almost it looked like watercolor to be
honest
of him uh you know jonathan price with
the top hat and all this other stuff and
he's with his hands out and then there's
like this big ball and like a carnival
like kind of
dim in the bottom with the two kids
running and it's just like it's a great
great like the color scheme is just
really nice i really really like the
poster for this but uh yeah so like like
i said i i feel like it was it's a good
movie but it was a little bit of a
missed opportunity so i'd really like to
see somebody else kind of take a whack
at it because i love the book um i'm i
really like ray bradberry stuff and i
really like this book it just it puts me
in the halloween mood like every time i
think about it so if you're looking for
something like that like for kids that
it's still pretty scary and it's still
kind of halloweeny has that halloween
retro vintage 50s kind of vibe to it
then you could certainly do worse than
this like i said this and the lady in
white would make a really good double
feature now that i'm thinking about it
maybe i'll do that maybe i'll do that
i'll just watch those two movies
together but yeah so that'll do it for
this eek week movie retrospective review
extra special uh for halloween week and
i will see you guys on the next one bye
[Music]
you